so when I was about 1920. I wouldn't say
I was like a feminist but I was
definitely you're one of those no no it
wasn't crazy about this but I was proud
you know to make my own money and I like
intellectual things I feel like politics
and crypto yeah that'll be fun to work
in that area and but as time's gone on
lucky I have an older brother I would
say he's definitely like knocked a lot
of ideas out of me maybe see things in a
leadership baby yes I have like this
trained mindset so I feel like my
brother's like prepared me for the right
man but I'm curious is there something
which men prefer a woman who he doesn't
need to train like she needs to be
trained to his liking right he likes
everything to go but I'm saying is that
more valued over a woman who doesn't
know anything and then you've got to
like take all this time to just like
train her and teach her and you know
debate with her